Their similarity makes them
more difficult to learn.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann, and today
I have a slightly different subject.
Uh, I spoke in a previous video about
how important it is to learn from things
that are familiar, but by the same token,
and the emphasis today is how difficult
it is to learn things that are similar.
Now, if you enjoy my
videos, please subscribe.
Click on the bell for notifications.
And if you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a comment.
I do appreciate it.
So what do I mean by that?
Well, I notice for example, that
whenever I start a new language, there
are words that sound very similar.
Uh ... you know, one is change, the
other is understand in Japanese.
It's very difficult to disentangle
these words that sound similar.
Another example is uh, very often, um,
well meaning people who write textbooks or
teachers will try to get you to learn, you
know, in chapter three, the colors, uh,
I remember I had a teacher once telling
me a tutor online, say, today we're
going to, we're gonna learn the colors.
It's very difficult because that, those
are similar, those are colors, and if
you try to learn the colors as a batch, I
personally find that very difficult to do.
The fact that they're all different
colors, one beside the other,
doesn't help me learn them.
The same is true if we talk about,
you know, the parts of the body
or numbers or the months of the
year, or the names of relatives.
You know, the cousin, boy cousin,
girl cousin, uh, in-law, mother's
side, father's side, you know,
wife's side, husband's side, all
of these things that are kind of
similar, their similarity makes them
more difficult to learn, thing...
to me.
And I'd be interested in fact in,
in hearing from people, whether
they have the same experience.
If you learn things that are all
different from each other, it's easier.
So, and if we can space the colors or
connect the colors to something else
like a plant or a red shirt, and we come
across them in different situations,
then eventually we assimilate those.
We start to learn them.
But if we try to learn them as a list,
I find that very difficult to do.
So any situation where things are
presented to us as a batch of things
to learn, it makes it more difficult.
Now, and the same goes
with synonyms, for example.
Or, uh, you'll sometimes get a
list of false friends, for example,
and supposed to, we're supposed to
notice how these, uh, false friends
don't mean in the new language what
they meant in the old language, but
going over them as a, as a list.
Here's a list of words that mean
something in language A, here's
what they mean in language B, that
connection from A to B doesn't help
me learn them has been my experience.
Uh, even things like, you know,
phrasal verbs that have the same verb.
Get, uh, get out of, get into, get on, get
up, get rid of the fact that they all have
the word get there may not be helpful.
Now I'm not, I haven't been in the
position of having to learn phrasal
verbs, but whenever I see these lists of
things that are similar, have the same
component in them, it, it's interesting.
It's interesting while I'm looking at
that list, and, and it may, in fact,
reviewing them as a list may help me.
I do that.
It's an activity that I do, but I think
it's a minor part of the learning process.
It's a review part of
the learning process.
In order to learn those things, we
actually have to find them, you know,
scattered, dispersed in content of
interest and, you know, see it here,
forget it, see it there, forget it.
And if we have enough input and if we
come across similar things, but we come
across them in isolated situations, in
different contexts, we're more likely
to learn them, whereas any attempt to
learn these similar things as a list is
probably not going to work that well.
At least that's been my experience, and
I think it relates somewhat, somewhat to
this idea of interleaving versus block
learning, that anytime you're trying to
master something by reading it over and
over again, whether it be a history paper
or a list of words, that's less effective
than finding it over here, finding it
over there, sort of grazing, interleaving.
So I leave that as a thought and I also
will believe you with a video that I've
done on interleaving and also one on,
you know, why we shouldn't, uh, engage
in sort of intensive, block learning.
So, uh, thank you for listening and
I look forward to your comments.
Bye for now.